tout de suite un gouvernement s'en va un
autre le remplace et entre les deux mais
on attend toujours ce ne sont pourtant
pas les urgences qui manque les dossiers
les chantiers s'accumulent sur le bureau
du chef de l'état alors quelles sont les
priorités du prochain gouvernement
gros plan à un mois des élections
législatives avec sandra sarah
la dégradation du pouvoir d'achat à
cause de l'inflation est bien le dossier
urgent du nouveau mandat d' emmanuel
macron en plus des 26 milliards d'euros
du bouclier tarifaire énergétique qui
comprend le gel des tarifs du gaz et
d'électricité où la remise carburant est
prévu dès cet été une loi exceptionnelle
pour le pouvoir d'achat elle prévoit
entre autres d'augmenter les pensions de
retraite de revaloriser les minima
sociaux et d'augmenter le point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires
n'est pas une crise qui s'est terminée
les choses vont ressurgir à nouveau
puisque le coville si la prise qu'ovide
s'amenuisent disparaît petit à petit ce
qu'on peut espérer cette fois merci
c'est le cas les autres crises vont
rejaillir vont revenir sur le devant de
la scène c'est un gros problème
autre chantier phare déjà très contesté
celui de la réforme des retraites qui
porte l'âge de départ à 65 ans d'ici
2031 emmanuel macron dit vouloir bâtir
un consensus et s'est dit prêt à bouger
s'il ya trop de tensions au four le
président est légitime mais la qualité
de son lien avec le pays est beaucoup
plus faible qu'elle
a juste titre
condamné deux fois pour une action
climatique lors du précédent quinquennat
l'exécutif sait qu'il est très attendu
sur le sujet le ou la chef du
gouvernement sera appuyée de deux
ministres forts en charge de la
planification écologique au programme
six nouveaux apn une augmentation du
renouvelable avec 50 parc éolien en mer
et l'objectif de baisser de 40 % de
notre consommation d'électricité d'ici
2050 concernant l'école la santé le
grand âge ou la justice emmanuel macron
n'a pas donné beaucoup de détails mes
débuts à il promettait de lancer des
réformes sur ces dossiers dès la
première année du nouveau quinquennat
les chantiers prioritaires du prochain
gouvernement la bataille des
législatives
on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir anne charlène bezina maître de
conférences en droit public j'accueille
à vos côtés albert est nouée d'acteurs
en chef du service politique du figaro
frédéric dabi directeur général de
l'ifop bonsoir frédéric et puis bien sûr
notre chroniqueuse laetitia croquant sur
laëtitia sa matière alors on croyait
jean castex parti ou sur le point de
partir et il est toujours là aujourd'hui
ils étaient sur le terrain dans le
vaucluse pour discuter avec des
agriculteurs il sera encore là dimanche
visiblement pour se déplacer au vatican
pour la canonisation de charles de
foucauld ça peut durer encore longtemps
le maire et nous donc je pense que ça
durera pas très longtemps on avait pensé
que ce serait cette semaine ouah en fin
de semaine l'événement c'est repoussé
encore de quelques jours dimanche pour
ce sera accomplie même même si c'est
encore possible il peut être démis de
ses fonctions fin a démissionné dimanche
et être au vatican dimanche puisque là
il sera en tant qu ancien premier
ministre ont reçu pendant la neuvaine
pas dans les mêmes conditions
protocolaire mais pour à l'est c'est pas
le plus probable c'est une visite
officielle dimanche c'est une visite
officielle dans tous les cas elle est
reçue avec le protocole du à lui à son
rang mais il pourrait ne pas être pour
être reçu mais en tant que comme je le
disais ex premier ministre met donc
c'est pas le plus probable je pense
qu'il restera premier ministre mais tout
est possible et dans ce cas là bas ça
voudrait dire que n'aurait un premier un
nouveau premier ministre en début de
semaine soit la dei marty après tout est
possible parce que le conseil nice ne
rend pas forcément lieu mercredi nous on
va avoir lieu le jeudi il faut le dire a
baissé
le conseil des ministres mercredi matin
c'est une c'est un usage quand les
gouvernements sont neufs sont formés et
donc une fois que
tant qu'il n'est pas formé on peut faire
un conseil des ministres jeudi lui peu
importe peu importe frédéric dabi est ce
que les français sur l'impasse et ans
j'ai envie de dire non il ya une
impatience médiatique d'un microcosme
qui à mon avis ne rejoint pas
complètement l'impatience des français
l'impatience des français on l'a très
bien vu dans votre reportage elle est
sur la question des enjeux et sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat sur cette
inflation qui revient alors qu'il avait
disparu du lot du langage des français
sur la question du coût de la vie sur la
question des matières premières la
question de l'énergie la relégation sur
la question de la santé il faut pas
oublier la santé c'est une enquête ifop
fiducial pour sud radio reste la
première préoccupation des français et
c'était une préoccupation qui a émergé
avants locaux vides parce qu'il y avait
près de l'hôpital le problème de l'accès
aux soins bien sûr
le casting et s'enfuit je pense que les
français sont moins sur la logique de
casting que sur une logique de résultats
on se souvient d'un une célèbre une de
libé qui avait fait polémique avec le
alors ça vient pour l'agonie du général
franco je ne crois absolument pas la
situation n'est politique
je ne sais même pas une agonie mathieu
parce que quand même ce qui est
absolument incroyable les deux premiers
premier ministre emmanuel macron auront
quitté l'hôtel matignon l'un dans une
situation d'état de grâce jamais vu
après trois ans de mandat et l'autre
avec une reconnaissance de l'opinion
publique avec une popularité ifop jdd
qui tangente les 45 ou les 46% donc ce
n'est absolument pas une agonie
politique mais voilà je pense que
l'impatience elle est là chez les
français ils ne sont pas dans la boîte à
idées pour les élections législatives il
commence à y entrer mais l'impatience
avait plutôt sur les enjeux sur les
dossiers prioritaires et sur l'action
alors un premier ministre un
gouvernement c'est un casting
particulier ce cas les erreurs à ne pas
commettre anne charlotte alors en tout
cas c'est un enjeu un très fort enjeu
parce que
la nomination du premier ministre et
jacques donne une couleur la composition
du gouvernement c'est le cap de la
politique les appellations des
portefeuilles le nombre de ministres
secrétaires d'état la féminisation ou
non savoir si on regarde l'économie avec
le budget savoir qui est ministre d'état
ou ne l'est pas c'est toute une
hiérarchie c'est toute une coutume dont
là aussi je suis pas sûr qu'elle
passionne complètement les français mais
qui en tout cas fait complètement partie
de notre république et et c'est vrai que
il ya évidemment des choses à mettre en
lumière c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on va choisir une appellation
un peu original pour un ministre de la
réforme du droit des femmes des minots
croisés sur l'écologie coup la
planification écologique on a déjà
quelques petits indices en effet
s'engager sur le fond ensuite donc c'est
vrai que toutes ces appellations là
elles peuvent paraître parfois un petit
peu ornementale or en réalité elles ont
elles ont du sens parce que
l'appellation d'un ministère c'est aussi
la manière dont on va lui donner des
choses à construire et donc on aura déjà
une indication sur le programme à partir
du moment où on aura l'appellation des
ministères donc on attend ce
gouvernement c'est sûr que le président
est maître des horloges l'a vraiment
totalement puisque l'article but lui
donne tous pouvoirs dont c'est à lui
décidé quand il nommera son premier
ministre lequel comment voilà jean
castex en attendant et d'une loyauté
d'une fidélité qui est vraiment digne de
cette fonction brin d'orgueil istres
voilà presque dans l'attentes voilà
c'est un équilibre politique aussi un
voilà c'est ce que j'allais dire c'est
assez on va re ça va refléter les
équilibres politiques et les échanges à
l'intérieur même de la majorité comment
sera traité par exemple edouard philippe
on sait qu'il ya des tensions au sein de
la majorité entre philippe et manu
accroc et respirant des philippines
il y en aura sans doute et combien à
quel poste les alliés donc le modem et b
où est ce que à mumbai rousse vous voyez
peut-être même premier ministre j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt une flamme
qui sera prise par exemple parce que
vous parlez en connaisseur les poêler au
beurre
dorian voiler l'horizon donc christian
estrosi par exemple qui a fait
visiblement des offres de service pour
entrer au gouvernement bonne question
que pose que posent les teasers ils se
sont pas tous les guinéens condamnons
hubert falco il ya des gens il ya des
gens calmes et kiki est plutôt donc des
bisons plutôt de à droite et l'air est
qui qui ont des ambitions ministérielles
on le sait est ce qu'ils seront est ce
qu'ils seront
entendus est ce qu'ils seront considère
d'ailleurs estrosi je le mets dans les
faits pis mais ils en train d'être un
peu plus tôt de partir du côté me mets
donc il ya un équilibre yann et qu'ils
étaient politiques à trouver au sein du
gouvernement c'est une équipe c'est une
équipe de france donc il faut que le
gardien soit aussi bon qu'avant centre
donc et tout ça c'est tout ça c'est à
regarder mais je vois que l'autre les
cales le fait qu' on attend de la
domination du premier ministre on le
voit c'est un peu pour ma cruz de
banaliser un peu l'événement on l'attend
depuis dix jours on pensait que cette
semaine ce sera sans doute au début
seulement je n'ai que ça ne sacralise
romane en tant que
ça devient quasiment un non-événement
qu'enfin pourri pour beaucoup de gens
c'est ça c'est quelque chose qui arrive
et puis voilà j'entends ce que dit
albert ça peut être vu comme un
non-événement mais c'est aussi un
événement de capital dans la campagne
pour les élections législatives quel
message on envoie vous avez parlé albert
de l' équilibre entre les différentes
sensibilités de la majorité notons qu'en
2017 la question ne se pose est
absolument pas on avait un gouvernement
si je puis dire dépolitiser même s'ils
avaient des chantiers de la gauche de la
droite mais c'était plutôt la ligne la
cohérence c'était un gouvernement qui
reflétait l'imaginaire des français qui
était ce serait formidable de faire un
gouvernement d'experts avec la
nomination d'une sportive aux sports
d'un médecin d'une médecin à des excuses
1 à la santé d'une ancienne drh à
l'emploi
l'éducation est un petit côté son mais
les gars du monde il y avait des côtés
de ceux smith au sénat le côté experts
là on est plutôt et là on retrouve ce
qu'on a vu pas de passer sous la gauche
à droite d un gouvernement qui est
beaucoup plus politique et qui reflète
aussi la composition des candidats de la
majorité qui ont été investis aux
législatives finis les amateurs c'est
plutôt des professionnels des gens qui
ont moins un mandat ou qui ont une
expérience politique il faut forcément
que ce soit une femme oui premier
ministre parce que il l'a déjà dit en
2017 il leur dit vraiment en 2022 donc
il me semble que bon après c'est mon
avis très personnel ce que va faire
emmanuel macron lui seul le sait et il
nous l'a montré auparavant qu'il peut
absolument choisir un homme de droite
technocrates jeudi il peut être
complètement à l'opposé de ce qu'il a
laissé entendre il ya une attente des
français sur ce sujet alors oui on avait
fait une enquête pour le journal du
dimanche le jdd.fr on avait de mémoire
deux tiers des français qui souhaitaient
qu'une femme accède à l'hôtel matignon
mais n'a eu qu'une fois une fois et ça a
duré dix mois jusqu'à une défaite
électorale cinglante aux régionales de
92 laëtitia a tout à fait raison le
président aime la surprise c'est
surprendre si me souviens bien en 2017
et albert a peut-être pu sauver leurs
cobras il y avait des dizaines de noms
qui avaient été lancées jassaud fait
dans philippe et jean castex que j'ai
pas souvenir que le nom soit sorti une
manière évidente donc voilà peut-être à
la toute fin donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent et ne pas jouer à du
name dropping et trouver des noms qui ne
seront peut-être démenti alors juste
avant de parler du prochain va quand
même juste refaire un petit zoom sur le
précédent jean castex qui a été salué
par le président lors du dernier conseil
des ministres saluent dans la majorité
aussi mais aussi par l'opposition à
l'image de gérard larcher le président
du sénat il était ce matin l'invité de
france info en écoute
à l'occasion de ces dernières questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
inscrite à notre ordre du jour la
suspension je tenais à vous remercier
russie le premier ministre pour la
constance de votre participation
j'ai ressenti que malgré parfois
certains irritants ou sentiers bien au
sénat j'ai essayé d'exercer ma fonction
dans le plus grand respect des
assemblées parlementaires de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat je vous ai
toujours parlé mais parler d'irritants
monsieur le président or il y en a eu
quelques fois mais en tout cas je vous
ai dis toujours ce que je pensais avec
sincérité et soyez en assurés dans le
seul but de rechercher l'intérêt général
alors vous aurez quand je vous même
s'était pas sur france info c'était un
échange aux questions au gouvernement le
23 février dernier tout de suite
j'appelle marion vigreux à nous
rejoindre
c'est marion quelle image va laisser
jean castex chez les sénateurs bien
plutôt un bon souvenir pour le sénat le
gascon descend un bon souvenir lui
reconnaît des qualités humaines il est
loyal amicales et sincères il comprend
les dossiers très vite c'est un bon
gestionnaire nous dit-on mais c'est
aussi un homme de dialogue et l écoute
jean castex à arrive à matignon à un
moment où les relations entre l'exécutif
et les collectivités locales les
parlementaires ne sont pas au beau fixe
et si les premiers mois sont un peu
poussif car jean castex ne maîtrise pas
vraiment le fonctionnement interne du
parlement sa connaissance des
territoires lui permet en revanche
d'établir une relation de confiance avec
les élus et je vous propose d'écouter à
ce sujet françois noël buffet le
président de la commission des lois
parfois que nous échange n'avait reçu je
me souviens très bien quand il appelle
ses fonctions pour échanger avec moi sur
les affaires et la compétence de la
commission des lois donc le lien était
beaucoup plus direct est beaucoup plus
facile ça n'était pas le cas avec une
fille c'était aussi une autre façon de
faire une autre façon de d'entretenir
des relations avec les élus
singulièrement de l'opposition puisque
je suis dans l'opposition
gouvernementale mais avec une discussion
simple direct et sur les sujets que les
gens connaissent et notamment évidemment
les préoccupations du quotidien que le
premier ministre semblait de connaître à
celle de jean castex a souvent été
présenté comme un homme de dossiers un
haut fonctionnaire et pour patrick
kanner le président du groupe socialiste
au sénat c'est une erreur de
appréciation à ses yeux jean castex est
un vrai politique un fin stratège et
c'est justement l'une des raisons de sa
longévité à matignon ecoutez-le avec une
forme de bonhomie un accent chantant qui
cache et un très grand professionnalisme
dire ce qu'ils ont sous-estimé qui vont
parfois caricaturé voilà notamment à la
télévision et bien se sont trompés donc
un homme qui a appliqué le programme des
manuels macro très clairement qui n'a
pas cherché à faire d'ombré aux
présidents sont vous les comparez
éventuellement à edouard philippe qui
commencé à apprendre le devant donc il a
été dans l'esprit de nicolas sarkozy
dans l'esprit finalement du quinquennat
aujourd'hui ce qui pose d'autres
problèmes institutionnels il a été un
très bon collaborateur et surtout il a
protégé le président de la république
mission peut-être qui est celle
aujourd'hui d'après ministre protection
du président mais aussi de ses ministres
jean castex a pu parfois prendre des
allures d'amortisseur nous dit on alors
qu'en est il de son bilan et bien sûr
des bancs de la droite on estime que sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire fut plutôt
réussie en revanche sur les retraites la
réforme de la justice la fracture
sociale rien n'a été réglé à gauche on
lui reproche d'avoir mené une politique
de droite est très à droite en
s'opposant par exemple à certaines
propositions de réformes écologiques ou
sociales comme le rsa jeunes mais
globalement au sénat on ne lui en tient
pas rigueur à l'image de cette formule
de patrick kanner jean castex a été un
bon chef d'orchestre mais la partition
n'était pas la sienne c'était celle du
jupitérien président de la république
quant à son avenir des rumeurs et voit
qu'une candidature possible aux
élections sénatoriales de l'année
prochaine dans son fief dans les
pyrénées orientales puisque le sénateur
l air france wasquehal clavet qui est
aussi son ami ne se représente pas
françois que la veille que nous avons
joint au téléphone qui nous confiant que
jean castex est très attaché au sénat
notamment parce que son grand père était
sénateur mais visiblement depuis son
passage à matignon ça n'intéresse plus
je vous propose qu'on en reparle de
l'année prochaine
merci merci beaucoup marion elmer et
nous ça va être facile de succéder à
jean castex
je pense que ça ne sera pas facile parce
que la situation est différente entre la
fin du mandat et le début de ce mandat
qui commence la situation économique est
totalement différente on était en effet
on est parti sur une fin de mandat
plutôt optimiste avec le retour de la
croissance des usa une petite inflation
et puis l'optimisme qui revenait est
pratiquement plus de chômage ou enfin
une baisse significative du chômage et
là un début de mandat où l'inflation est
galopante les déficits se creusent la
croissance est atone donc on va se
retrouver sans doute avec une rentrée
chaude comme on dit toujours mais mais
en tous les cas une rentrée sociale
compliqué et ça va ça veut dire que pour
un premier ministre commencée dans une
situation ça va ça va pas être simple il
va falloir pour lui trouver non
seulement les hommes mais trouver les
arguments et et convaincre une opinion
qui est très très partagés sur sur même
sur le sur le sur le sort du premier
ministre et sur le sort du président de
la république alors je suis désolé il ya
un fruit des lions face mais mon sort un
sondage aux docks ça dans nos pages
aujourd'hui enfin qui sortira demain et
qui montrent que les français sont très
sceptiques sur le nouveau président de
la république le nouveau mac rentrait
élan novotel résidents des autres il ya
une attente qui est qui et qui est qui
et qui va être compliqué pour le premier
ministre et paie pour l'exécution en
général juste un dernier mot de ce
casting est ce qu'on sait
ceux qui partent et ceux qui restent je
parle pas de ceux qui arrivent parce
qu'il est toujours des rumeurs mais est
ce qu est ce qu on sait par exemple ceux
qui partent y en a on se sait qu'ils
vont se faire on peut se perdre en
conjectures on peut faire des paris il y
a des gens note on sait qu'il pourrait
partir principalement c'est jean michel
blanquer que ça fait pas il a dit mais
même sur la tête je vais par piqué ouvre
l'album que je répliqué eric
dupond-moretti marlène schiappa et à dia
des grans par nice matin jean laurens
par lit ce matin au journal séquelles
qu'elle ne voulait pas qu'elle ne
voulait pas continuer
dégoûtant des gros ministères des
personnes qui comptent il y en a
d'autres qui vont rester sans doute ça
reste là aussi on ne sait pas mais on
pense que bruno le maire gérald hamada
son a amené plus tôt à rester et
d'autres aussi mais voilà ça reste quand
même un équilibre particulier c'est le
président qui choisit alors sur
nomination du premier ministre mais on
sait très bien que c'est le présent de
avec kindy choisi et
c'est que sur proposition du pont du
problème du premier ministre met donc ça
le tout est dans les mains du président
de la république en fait il a réglé les
investiture de l'arrêt mais de
renaissance on voit bien que le
gouvernement ce sera lui qui décide et
ce qu'ils veulent voir la distribuer les
portefeuilles liszt et vous vous êtes
intéressé à un autre poste créé souvent
méconnu celui enfin méconnu autrefois
mais c'est bien connu du grand public
aujourd'hui celui le porte parole du
gouvernement ah oui parce que c'est
simple mathieu si le premier ministre
est le collaborateur le protecteur on a
même entendu monsieur canardière
protecteur du président est bien le
porte parole c'est tout simplement la
bouche les mots les idées des manuels
macro et on on l'a vu d'ailleurs ça
s'est affinée avec avec les années parce
qu'au début du quinquennat c'était
christophe castaner qui est arrivé avec
un autre poste celui de secrétaire
d'état chargé des relations avec le
parlement et puis à l'arrivée de six
bêtes ndiaye on lui admis uniquement
cette caste est qd cette casquette sur
la tête et donc s'occuper uniquement du
porte parolat du gouvernement avec quel
bilan mitigé voilà quelques petites
sorties de piste joue oppose peut être
la plus célèbre celle qui est restée
c'était le 20 le en mars 2020 les
masques ne sont pas nécessaires pour
tout le monde et vous savez quoi moi je
sais pas utiliser un masque je pourrais
dire je suis mini je me mets un masque
mais en fait je sais pas l'utiliser
parce que l'utilisation d'un masque ce
sont des gestes techniques précis sinon
on se gratte le nez sous le masque en
fait on a du virus sur les mains sinon
on a une utilisation qui n'est pas bonne
et ça peut être même contre-productif
voilà ce je ne sais pas mettre un masque
moi même alors que je suis ministre lui
est resté comme le sparadrap
indécollable du capitaine haddock et
peut-être qu après l e emmanuel macron à
décider quand même de resserrer un petit
peu les boulons et de faire un casting
peut-être plus fiable et il a choisi
gabriela talent qui s'est révélée dans
se rueront filtres différents et
gabriela talent il a vraiment été le
lieutenant le plus fidèle des manuels
macron jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat et cette fois on a une idée
qu'il est pressenti pour le poste est
écoutée emmanuel macron à 10 1 la
semaine dernière à un début de semaine à
berlin qu'il savait qui était son
premier ministre il semblerait qu'ils
sachent aussi qui est son futur porte
parole du gouvernement alors il se
murmure que ce serait une femme là
encore mathieu c'est bon décidément ça
veut dire que peut-être qu'il n'a pas
trouvé un premier ministre famé qui va
le mettre au porte parole du
gouvernement il ya des noms qui
circulent comme olivier à grégoire
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
économie ou un mode brégeon pas très
connu du grand public porte parole trait
sur les pâtes oui voilà porte parole de
l air em qui se présente d'ailleurs aux
élections législatives mais bon comme
vous l'avez dit c'est un des postes
vraiment central dans la communication
aujourd'hui du président qui on le sait
ne va rien changer à mon avis à son
style de gouvernance donc c'est un poste
à regarder de près merci on va on va
parler des chantiers maintenant frédéric
dabi sur quoi est attendu le prochain
gouvernement l'inflation oui je pense
que c'est le pouvoir d'achat qui a tout
écrasé cas structurer toute la campagne
présidentielle qui était de premier
déterminant du vote qui contribue
fortement au pessimisme je rebondis sur
ce qu'a dit
albert et nous il s'est passé quelque
chose de très rare on a reposé notre
question historique sur l'optimisme ou
le pessimiste pour l'avenir des français
et l'avenir de leurs enfants pour la
première fois sous la vème république
après une campagne présidentielle
l'optimisme a décru d'une quinzaine de
points traditionnellement la campagne
c'est un moment cathartique où les
français ont débattu au vu des candidats
échanger sur leurs programmes ont montré
de la crédibilité et le pays si je peux
dire part à l'assaut des défis qui lui
sont confiées et il ya un moment qui
durent au moins en moins de temps mais
d'état de grâce aux orres en tout cas de
bienveillance là ils sont déprimés je
dirais que le pessimisme est très est
très fort il est de l'ordre de deux
tiers c'était à une enquête ifop
fiducial poursuivre radio de la semaine
dernière et c'est vrai que sur les
chantiers j'ai l'impression que le la
question de la hausse des prix et
pouvoir d'achat qui a complètement
éclipsé le chômage maintenant
l'injustice suprême pour les français ce
n'est plus être au chômage savoir un
travail qui paye mal un travail qui ne
permet pas de vivre et l'inflation c'est
une c'est une mauvaise c'est comment
dire lorsqu'il sera donc il bascule pour
un sou le bilan sur le chômage était
plutôt pas ouvert
on en parle de plus tout à fait mais là
ce qui est très intéressant c'est de
voir je pense qu'il ya d'autres enjeux
la santé on en a parlé l'éducation la
fin des bancaires a été un petit peu
compliqué mais c'est vraiment sur une
question d des carburants de l'énergie
de la hausse des prix que le
gouvernement va être le plus attendu est
las de ce point de vue là l'impatience
de l'opinion est absolument très forte
albert à nous les 100 jours c'est un
mythe ou une réalité politique l'idée
qu' il faut faire un tout dans les 100
premiers jours parce qu'elle prendrait
plus
les deux mon général c'est ça ça ça
répond maintenant à une exigence
d'efficacité rapide les gouvernements
les présidents ont compris que si on ne
faisait pas tout tout de suite je
reviens machiavel qui l'avait prophétisé
saaq avait théorisé ça donc si on fait
pas tout tout de suite c'est difficile
et ce qui est vrai c'est de plus en plus
difficile donc on peut profiter de
l'état de grâce le poème de mâcon c'est
que le talent grâce
semble pas être être au rendez-vous
semble pas qu'il y ait une volonté de
des français 2 de porter le président de
la république alors mais quand vous
voulez mesurer ça parce que quand même
quand on regarde ces chiffres moi
j'entends c'est ces commentaires ils
sont constants et ils sont partagés
quasiment partout les observateurs mais
comment vous pouvez dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'état de grâce dans la population voit
dans les
le deuxième mandat ça reste très
compliquée alors
président en la personne je pense que
c'est une erreur et une faute même de
remettre en cause la légitimité d'un
président élu ou a fortiori
réélu mais c'est vrai que françois
mitterrand avait connu une sorte d'état
de grâce parce qu'il y avait cet
attelage cette forme de cohabitation
havre ailleurs avec michel rocard là
c'est vrai que les indicateurs
économiques sont extrêmement mal perçue
par les français les français sortent
d'une succession de crises crise
sanitaire crise terroriste faut pas
oublier à quel point l assassinat de
semaine patty a marqué pour ne pas dire
traumatisé des français la guerre au
coeur de l'europe tout ça n'incite pas à
l'optimisme ça veut pas dire qu'elles
macro et va être comme anti redescendu
en femme et va s'effondrer dans les
enquêtes de popularité et n'a pas une
puisque a pas de pré ministre
qui montrait que 70% des français
n'était pas content de la réélection des
milieux bacon alors même qu'ils ont voté
pour lui le paradoxe le père c'est la
raison par l'absolu il n'y a pas d'effet
nouveauté non il y avait une certaine
honda envoya pas vraiment d'état de
grâce s'il ya des dossiers difficiles
qui attendent ça veut dire quoi c'est ça
qu'il faut changer de méthode pour le
président alors c'est en tout cas ce
qu'il a promis et moi je crois que cet
état de grâce qui n'a pas finalement on
l'a vu le soir même du deuxième tour
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
de célébrer cela on est directement
parti dans une bataille à dominer mme
sur les législatives sur la légitimité
du président hu en lice c'est une
première fois sous la vème république
donc je crois vraiment que ya une
urgence sociale on commence à parler
avant les états d'urgence en tant que
juriste moi j'ai un peu de mal avec sam
enfin mon a fait lui l'état d'urgence
terroristes on a fait l'état d'urgence
sanitaire maintenant on parle d'état
d'urgence sociale donc c'est dire à quel
point finalement que fallout crise alors
j'ai tendance à penser que ça fait manon
thurgoviens bus vers l'egypte veut dire
que dès qu'il ya une crise et une
urgence donc c'est très dangereux pour
notre gouvernance parce que ça signifie
qu'à partir du moment où il faut faire
quelque chose d'important on a
l'impression que c'est une urgence
gouvernementale est donc en plus on
sollicite des procédures d'urgence au
parlement qui n'est pas forcément de
plus plus heureux depuis cette dernière
est là il ya des réformes structurantes
qui attend le gars est donc on parle de
la santé d'éducation des retraites et
pouvoir d'achat la session
extraordinaire va évidemment s'ouvrir
sur ce paquet pouvoir d'achat alors qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus tout à fait un
paquet mais qui serait formée la loi de
finances rectificative et d'un premier
projet de loi mais c'est pour ça que je
pense que la composition du gouvernement
est loin d'être anecdotique parce que à
mon avis il ya quand même une urgence de
la part des français de voir qu'est ce
qui va être concrètement proposés et on
l'a dit l'état économique il va pas
pouvoir rester comme ça très longtemps
parce qu'il faut penser aussi au
principe de réalité c'est à dire que le
quoi qu'il en coûte un petit peut
laisser penser que les finances étaient
finalement un an me dire la viande ans
suivra comme nous disait le général de
gaulle or ça ne pourra pas durer la
banque centrale le fait savoir donc là
on est vraiment dans quelque chose qui
va devoir être décisif et on dit souvent
que ce sont françois dans le disait
souvent que ce sont les premières
mesures fiscales qui donne la coloration
d'un quinquennat 2007 par les deux
chiens voilà voir pour amener de macron
avec cautionner la suppression de 55
d'heuliez sait quelle va être la
coloration pour vous une quinzaine de ce
début de quinquennat je pense que alors
l'idée qui est communément admis c'est
que le premier ministre serait plutôt
une femme plutôt orienté sociale
écologique donc on peut penser que pour
ce deuxième mandat il soit plutôt portée
vers la gauche et avec avec un profil
venant de la gauche ce kit un trait
toute l'action gouvernementale d'une
teinte social avec un premier texte
symbolique sur ce paquet pouvoir d'achat
là donc ça pourrait être ça et ça
pourrait donner ça pourrait donner le la
de tout le tout le quinquennat la
difficulté c'est ce que c'est ce que me
disait ah des conseillers a conseillé
tous des cas c'est que ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de temps pour agir on revient
un peu la notion des 100 jours mais là
c'était y penser que ça tiendrait deux
ans qu au bout de deux ans ce serait
très très compliqué que la majorité
commencerait à déjà à être beaucoup plus
compliqué plus difficile dans le code
d'entrée est déjà dans le coup d'après
bien sûr le premier jour du mandat de
d'emmanuel macron c'est un peu son
dernier jour puisque aurélie jour du
reste de ta vie de son mandat donc et
est donc tous les sites ou les
successeurs potentiels ont commencé à se
réveiller bon on va parler un peu
maintenant des législatives avec cette
nouvelle qui est tombée en fin de
matinée sur twitter ce suspense
insoutenable
eric zemmour sera candidat aux
législatives dans la 4e circonscription
du var celle de sa trompés et trompé en
sont également opposés à saint tropez
disait max pécas on peut le voir sur ce
twitt albert cellou pourquoi là bas
parce que parce que là il ya deux
droites nationalistes la droite
nationale du nord qui est plutôt
rassemblement national la droite
nationaliste du sud qui est plus orienté
et plus facilement un cas qui est plus
réceptive aux thèses d'eric zemmour donc
et et de cette 4e circonscription du var
c'est une circonscription qui qui est
sociologiquement un peu plus favorisés
et donc qui est là aussi plus réceptive
aux thèses d'analyser les lignes a fait
un bon score
mais je crois que marine le pen est
arrivée devant lui dans ses conclusions
donc c'est quand même c'est un pari mais
je pense qu' il ne pouvait pas ne pas y
aller c'est la première épreuve du feu
pour reconquête qui est un parti déjà
puissant avec beaucoup de militants
voilà
est-ce que le pas je suis ça qu'est ce
que c'est accepté par les forts surtout
dans ce type de région mais parce
que c'est là je partage ce que vous dite
c'est très vrai pour une élection
municipale
c'est très bon et sur les chats tiff qui
fait suite à une présidentielle où il a
voulu se présenter comme le candidat
pour être président de tous les français
on se souvient de parachutage réussi
jean luc mélenchon en 2010 est du côté
de marseille alors je dis pas que tu vas
gagner si c'est une épreuve face on a
gagné face à ceux diffusés forcer le
cours de l'histoire on se souvient de
ségolène royal dépêché par françois
mitterrand dans les deux sèvres
et non mais effectivement il peut y
avoir du rejet était difficile pour un
port est risible de patrouille bien sûr
content d un défenseur et dans la
mémoire de bonaparte et de napoléon on
se doit d'être sur le pont d'arcole est
de mener la bataille donc il fallait il
fallait qu'il en soit combien peut
espérer une reconquête ont cédé 7 une
femme eric alors c'est difficile de vous
répondre comme ça je pense que les gains
seront relativement modeste reconquête
est arrivé en tête quasiment aucune
circonscription il a été quasiment sans
fin et risée ou en parlant devant marine
le pen il était systématiquement ou
presque devancé par la candidate du
rassemblement national mais il ya une
question de financement public avec si
leurs gonds qu'elle fait dans 50
circonscriptions - au moins 1% ce qui
paraît quand même atteignable et puis
comme le disait albert il faut que le
chef donne un exemple qui aille mais il
est possible il est possible ce n'est
pas un pronostic c'est une possibilité
une hypothèse que reconquête
entre 0 et 2 députés et risée mots pour
être celui là mais je le répète il va
être sans doute face à philippe lottiaux
qui est un frontiste historique bien
implanté ce sera d'abord pour lui une
primaire face aux arènes comme un peu à
la présidentielle
et l'udc en 2017 avant elle avait
toujours perdu sur toujours justement
marine le pen
visiblement il n'y avait rien à attendre
du côté de marine le pen pour eric
zemmour elle l'a redit et redit écouter
ce qu'elle disait encore hier c'était
sur sur rtl d'élite définitivement à
ceux qui nous ont quittés pour eric
zemmour c'est un chemin sans retour
c'est ça que vous leur dites oui enfin
vous parlez des quatre là oui oui les
quatre c'est un chemin sans le temps
mais je ne suis pas isolé j'ai réuni 13
millions d'électeurs au second tour je
me sens assez peu isolé photo dette ça
fait pas une majorité très imminent mais
ça aurait pas une majorité mais j'ai
déjà rassemblé charlene on parlait des
espoirs de conquête mais ils sont très
très minces et je vous écoute pour
reconquête est ce qu'eric zemmour peut
se relever d'une défaite aux
législatives après sa défaite à la
présidentielle ou est-ce que ça risque
d'enterrer son son avenir politique les
législatives sont un moment politique
très dure pour les partis qui ont été
constitués sur une personnalité au cours
d'une présidentielle qui a tendance
quand même à a unifié autour d'un homme
autour d'un nom et c'est alors
reconquête joue sur une idéologie donc
est-ce que celle là va prendre il ya
quand même une épreuve du feu en effet
sur ces législatives et est-ce qu'on
pourrait se relever alors gens me dire
un à deux députés ça paraît tout à fait
modique mais c'est vrai que je crois que
le modem en 2007 au sortir justement de
cette peopolisation françois bayrou on
obtient quatre ou cinq et pourtant par
la suite on implante un petit peu
localement donc les choses se font
politiquement entre contrairement à ce
qu'on croit avec la présidentielle en
réalité dans les assemblées assez petit
à petit et avoir une assise locale jeu
je crois pouvoir dire d'ailleurs qu'en
marche aujourd'hui on n'a encore pas
vraiment c'est très long c'est très
laborieux mais ça commence comme ça donc
d'un long chemin
il avait très bien dit seuil et au
caractère un peu mixte du scrutin
législatif national avec en plus
l'impact effet de souffle présidentielle
mais un scrutin éminemment locales et
puis surtout au lendemain du second tour
des législatives nous entrons dans une
sorte de désert électoral rien en 2022
20 sauf référendum 2023 des sénatoriales
mais les français ne sont pas concernés
2024 élections européennes qu'un scrutin
j'ai envie d'un malheureusement des
français votent très peu 2025 pas
d'élection ça sera un quinquennat de ce
point de vue là avec sauf référendum que
nous ne connaissons pas mais c'est un
cetain il n'a pas eu depuis 2005 comme
vous le savez en france métropolitaine
voilà on est c'est à dire que l'épreuve
du feu eric zemmour c'est le second
drissa par une victoire ou de symbolique
pour être voilà le le prêt d'une dune on
marche dans une forme de désert alberte
raynaud voulait réagir le l'objet je
pense que là ce que ce que veut et c'est
absolument éviter l'exode bourse est
d'avoir un destin à la philippe de
villiers une participation en présentiel
pas trop mauvaise et puis à un long
chemin qui s'étiole et qui osera
qualifie les débours soir le jeu nous
aurons alors un nicolas dupont aignan ou
à nicolas dupont aignan donc se
retrouver un peu seul un épiphénomène et
lille 3
le personnel pour pourrir ex-aequo il
faut il faut qu'ils tiennent au moins
jusqu'en 2024 l'objectif c'est ça c'est
se retrouver dans un scrutin national de
liste ou en général les partis tels que
le sien peut faire des peut faire une un
score et après relancer la machine pour
les trois ans qui reste laetitia pour
vous c'est une erreur de la part marine
le pen ne pas accepter la main tendue
non c'est impossible avec les messages
qu'ils ont envoyé les uns et des autres
pendant toute toute la campagne c'était
impossible pour elle avec eric zemmour a
dit au soir du premier tour enfin elle
ces messages pour y envoyer quand vous
voyez n'est pas le parti socialiste en
c'était
[Musique]
celle de marine le pen en tout cas et en
dans le cadre de pensée du
rnd du fn parce qu'il ya vraiment tout
un corpus comme ça idéologique mais même
dans les méthodes et dans les façons de
faire c'était impossible alors
déplu à sa base militante qui quand même
et toujours à 90% fidèles ça je crois
que je sais pas si elle pleure avec des
plumes et je crois que ce qui a scellé
le sort de la deûle à lyon c'est ce qu'a
dit eric zemmour le soir du crime
défaite au second tour avec de l'eau
chaude et ces
débats au total on va finir avec avec
jean luc mélenchon qui lui ne veut pas y
aller ces législatives
frédéric dabi est ce que la dynamique
d'abord de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale se traduit dans
les sondages relativement puisque dans
notre première mesure il faut ficelles
pour lci on à une l'alliance du ps qui
arrive symboliquement en tête devant la
majorité présidentielle qui en retard de
cinq points par rapport à ce qu'elle va
obtenu en 2017 ya un match il ya une
stratégie d'eric mélenchon qui a été
validé son sa stratégie d'union de main
tendue même si dans une logique c'est
une jcct d'hégémonie très forte sonné sa
stratégie de saturation de l'espace
médiatique en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il
ya une même c'est une déperdition il ya
un électorat de gauche qui nie cette
démocrate qui n'a absolument pas dans
cette nouvelle alliance qui pourra aller
la dynamique politique s'est traduite du
quartier c'est très dynamique avec toi
le fait qu' il y là vraiment je dirais
fait tourner l'agenda médiatique il a
centré l'agenda médiatique autour de lui
maintenant qu'il ne soit pas candidat
c'est relativement gênant il yal'idée
animal l'image qu'albert a utilisé du
général de com de bonaparte au pont
d'arcole mais et puis aussi on pourra
lui dire lisez mon prémunissent oui mais
d'abord et vous vous même en devenant
s'il faisait réélire le député de
marseille notamment mais quand est-ce
qu'ils répondraient c'est bien sûr une
censure sur france inter ce week-end il
était interviewé dimanche je me prépare
plutôt à l'idée d'être premier ministre
qu'à l'idée d'être de nouveau député ce
monsieur castex a été désigné j'ai dit
hier j'espère qu'il n'a pas pris ma lin
je lui ai dit qu'un sympa et il avait
été élu à prades avec 1800 vois ça lui
donne une légitimité inité à brad may
moi j'estime que 7 millions 700 mille
voix l'élection présidentielle bon ça
fait pas de moi tout à fait un passant
dans la rue à l'inversé nous à quoi il
joue dans les chambres ils jouent tous
les cas il a bien joué puisque il a
réussi avec le troisième tour cette
notion au troisième tour et de premier
ministre ben à transformer une défaite
puisqu'il n'a pas réussi à se qualifier
au second tour et ben en quasi victoire
on a on a oublié qu'il n'était pas
présent au second tour est effectivement
comme disait frédéric et à une dynamique
qui semble qui semble prendre alors sans
doute qu'il n'ira pas jusqu'à ce qu'il
n'ira pas jusqu'à la la majorité absolue
à l'assemblée mais en tous les cas il
peut il peut constituer une majorité un
groupe très fort et je rappelle que
l'alors le le premier groupe
d'opposition a le droit à un poste très
important c'est les présences la
présence de la commission des finances
qui a vraiment un vrai statut est une
vraie il ne va vrai enjeu est donc et
pour aimer pour
mélenchon il ya une volonté de faire
passer de cette défaite comme une
victoire mais aussi là où il avait dit
qu'il se serait sa dernière date c'est
un passage de témoin vous pensez à le
fait qu'ali pas moi je pense qu'il sait
pas sur qui la qu'elle renonce
complètement à l'élection présidentielle
oui ah ça c'est sûr mais
c'est sûr qu'il n'ira pas jusqu'au peut
être promu niçois avoir été député entre
charlene oui oui vous faites pour les
mini sans avoir été déploré est élu
habitation
avec nos profils dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure je crois que la figure est
assez maligne parce que finalement il
nous dit moi je ne vais pas aller mettre
les mains dans la réalité politique de
l'élection législative parce que moi je
vais jouer l'idéologie de cette nuit
pèse parce qu'on vient de la voir
arriver on sait pas à quoi elle
correspond et donc c'est lui qui va être
le ciment tout ça ça c'est fait derrière
lui il veut donner notre 6
intellectuelle il veut donner le cap il
veut que ça ne dure pas uniquement sur
cette élection mais sur plusieurs autres
donc il a un rôle j'ai envie de dire
presque 2 de management dans tous acquis
qu'il entend assumer donc c'est pas
complètement
je ne vais pas au combat c'est
finalement j'emmène un autre et puis
c'est aussi une manière pour lui de dire
mais il ya des nouveautés il faut que je
crée une nouvelle équipe donc ils
essayent d'obtenir de la sympathie de
partout ce qui en soit me paraît tout à
fait opportun il faut savoir aussi qu'il
esquive les règles du csa en se
promettant du coup de pouvoir parler au
nom des autres sans être complètement
des comptes et pensant c'est d'ailleurs
devenu l'art comme entre temps je lui
fais pas mais il y a en effet cette idée
de de gagner un petit peu sur tous les
plans est ce qu'après en termes de
légitimité démocratique
moi cette idée du troisième tour mary
beaucoup parce que bon comme on l'a dit
il ya quand même déjà vraiment des logis
qui sont tellement différentes avec la
la législative et puis aller à
l'affrontement alors qu'on avait déjà
une france tellement fracturé
directement dans cette élection
législative est ce que c'est le bon
message est ce que c'est ce que les
français souhaitent il faut bien le
rappeler en tout cas qu'un président
seul ne peut absolument rien faire sous
la vème république donc élire quelqu'un
pour ensuite élire une majorité
différente ça revient à vouloir bloquer
le système escaliers marine le pen
d'ailleurs quand on leur dit que si on
suit les institutions normalement le
président a à sa majorité pour gouverner
c'est ce qui s'est passé depuis 2002 la
version de l'électorat de mais c'est
vrai que ce qu'il fait ça permet de
créer de la mobilisation on sait très
bien que le nerf de la guerre pour niche
tati vous ça va toujours beaucoup moins
qu'une présidentielle est dense et la
mobilisation des électeurs et là dans
les projections il faut que ne fais pas
de projection par instant nous pourquoi
c'est intéressant ça pour moi c'est
non l'offre électorale des spectateurs
certains instituts de sondage on joue la
projection de la future assemblée
nationale est un travail servir en
nombre de sièges premier tour
d'hypothèses de de second tour sur un
travail politologique de l'histoire des
circonscriptions mais je trouve qu'on
mélange un travail sondages et avec un
travail pointu logique nous le ferons
pour tf1 c'est à la fin du mois de mai
quand l'offre sera connu et quand la
campagne on a véritablement commencé on
nationalise des voeux pour un scrutin
qui est plutôt localisés avec des
figures
aussitôt changé avec l'argent assez fort
entre ces institutions notamment le
poids du rassemblement la semaine